I think it's really going to be
dependent on the kinds of choices people
make.
Um,
I,
you know,
I suppose I would be,
I do more optimistic if I felt other
people were,
uh,
less irrationally optimistic.
I think people are not fully aware of
some of the risks and some of the
challenges we face and because of that
are overly complacent.
And I think that's,
that seems to me is,
uh,
a recipe for,
um,
dramatically increasing the probability,
something very bad,
um,
bad happening.
Um,
but,
uh,
but you know,
these things are very,
it's very hard to,
it's very hard to know and you know,
it,
uh,
it's very hard to know which choices are
going to be the critical ones and how
these things are precise and work out
because the world's a big place.
A lot of complicated things are,
are going on.
Um,
I,
I tend to,
I guess my,
if I had,
if I had to makeup,
if you held a gun to my head,
forced me to make a prediction.
I think we're headed towards,
um,
you know,
20,
30 years of incredible chaos and
turmoil.
And then at the tail end of,
we will emerge with a world better than
any weekend
now.
Yeah.